hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 63 y hablaremos del
cociente de reacción uno de mis juegos
favoritos cuando era niña eran las
escondidillas pero muchas veces al final
quedaba alguien que seguía escondido y
la persona que lo estaba buscando no lo
podía encontrar así que terminamos
jugando frío o caliente si se acercaba
le decíamos que estaba tibio o caliente
y si estaba lejos decíamos que estaba
frío entonces en una reacción reversible
sucede algo muy parecido identificamos a
la constante de equilibrio acá como una
relación entre los productos y los
reactivos en una reacción reversible
pero sólo la podemos calcular cuando
alcanzamos el equilibrio cuando
encontramos lo que estábamos buscando
pero en ciencia también tenemos un
cociente de reacción q que se calcula de
la misma forma pero que se puede
calcular antes de alcanzar el equilibrio
así que nos permite saber qué tan lejos
estamos del equilibrio
justamente como jugar frío o caliente
ahora en una reacción reversible los
reactivos se convierten en productos y
los productos en reactivos y
eventualmente con el tiempo la reacción
alcanza el equilibrio y cuando llegamos
al equilibrio podemos calcular la
constante de equilibrio k que es
simplemente igual a la concentración de
los productos entre la concentración de
los reactivos pero a lo largo de ese
proceso también podemos calcular q que
es igual a la concentración de los
productos entre la de los reactivos pero
en cualquier momento de la reacción y
con el tiempo el valor de q se va
acercando hasta que es igual acá y eso
es cuando alcanzamos el equilibrio
entonces un modelo de eso podría ser así
imaginen que tenemos un diagrama de
energía libre y la pelota rueda de un
lado a otro pero supongamos que la
detenemos justo aquí entonces el fondo
corresponde acá y en donde nos
encontramos ahora sería
por lo tanto sabemos que la pelota se
moverá hacia la izquierda y si la
dejamos rodar un poco más y la detenemos
ahora tenemos otra q y sabemos que la
pelota ahora se moverá hacia la derecha
hasta que llegamos al equilibrio
entonces si usamos un diagrama de
energía como este que se encuentra justo
aquí y que puede encontrarse en
cualquier otro punto aquí tenemos un
modelo para una reacción reversible del
lado izquierdo tenemos muchas moléculas
del compuesto a que cuando pasan al lado
derecho se convierten en b entonces lo
que estoy haciendo es simplemente
mantener un registro del número de
reactivos y productos los reactivos
están identificados de color verde y los
productos de color rojo y hago un
registro cada 50 segundos y miren al
principio hay una gran diferencia
empezamos con 100 de reactivos y 0 de
productos pero al pasar los 300 segundos
el sistema empieza a estabilizarse
entonces si usamos estos datos y los
gráfica mos nos queda esto observen que
al principio tenemos todos los reactivos
y nada de productos pero con el tiempo
alcanzamos el equilibrio este es
solamente un modelo pero como podemos
calcular la constante de equilibrio
bueno simplemente es igual a la
concentración de los productos entre la
de los reactivos y en este caso la
concentración de nuestros productos es
65 y de los reactivos es 35 entonces
podemos decir que acá es 1.9 así que al
final cuando la reacción alcanza el
equilibrio podemos decir que el valor de
acá es de 1.9 pero cuál es el valor de q
bueno q son todos los valores que se
puedan calcular a lo largo de la
reacción antes de que alcancemos el
equilibrio así que el valor de q en
nuestro primer punto es igual a 0 y como
lo calculé
simplemente dividiendo el número de
productos que en este caso es
entre el número de reactivos que es 100
y eso nos da un valor de q igual a 0
ahora a los 50 segundos al dividir 42
entre 58 eso es igual a 0.72 y ahora
veamos qué pasa con q conforme nos
acercamos cada vez más al equilibrio
como pueden ver se estabiliza un poco
aquí pero todavía no tenemos suficientes
productos y luego el valor de q se eleva
un poco más y después sigue cambiando
hasta que eventualmente q es igual acá
entonces este es solo un modelo pero nos
muestra lo que sucede en una reacción
química recuerden que es lo que tenemos
al final y q es lo que tenemos
antes de eso y bueno para resumir un
poco en una reacción reversible si el
valor de q es menor al valor de k
entonces la reacción tiene que moverse
hacia la derecha es decir que
necesitamos convertir más reactivos en
productos pero si el valor de q
es mayor acá entonces la reacción va
hacia la izquierda y si el valor de q es
igual acá entonces nos encontramos al
equilibrio ahora algunas veces es
difícil recordar esto pero si usamos una
recta numérica eso nos puede ayudar un
poco por ejemplo si ponemos estos
valores de cv y de acá en una recta
numérica acá es en donde queremos estar
y q es en donde nos encontramos en este
momento en qué dirección tenemos que
movernos claro tenemos que movernos
hacia la izquierda así que necesitamos
convertir más de nuestros productos en
reactivos para alcanzar el equilibrio
ahora esto solo funciona en un sistema
homogéneo es decir si trabajamos con
líquidos y sólidos o gases y sólidos o
sólidos y líquidos este cociente de
reacción no funcionará y bueno si lo
aplicamos a una reacción química moderna
aquí tenemos esta reacción reversible
dos moles de esto
producen un molde esto y dos de esto y
podemos usar algo que se llama tabla y
se se conoce como tabla hice porque aquí
tenemos la concentración inicial la
concentración en el cambio y la
concentración al equilibrio y pse-ee y
todo esto se mide en concentración molar
entonces si calculamos cuál es el valor
de q para esto podemos ver que no
tenemos productos
así que nuestra q será igual a 0 y para
calcular el valor de k necesitamos las
concentraciones al equilibrio les
enseñaré cómo calcularlo en el siguiente
vídeo pero de momento les puedo decir
que en este caso acá es igual a 650
entonces hacia qué dirección se moverá
la reacción se moverá hacia la derecha o
se moverá hacia la izquierda bueno si
pusiéramos los valores de acá y de cv en
una recta numérica veríamos que necesita
moverse hacia la derecha lo cual tiene
sentido porque necesitamos convertir
esto
activos en productos claros y queremos
alcanzar el equilibrio así que la
reacción se favorecerá hacia la derecha
y para obtener los valores al equilibrio
una vez que ya conocemos estos valores
simplemente los restamos y así es como
tenemos este y podemos ver un patrón en
la fila de las concentraciones en el
cambio todos estos valores corresponden
al mismo cambio de molar y da y porque
es la misma bueno porque observen que
tenemos la misma cantidad de moles aquí
arriba y si observamos este valor que es
de 0.0 19 eso es porque sólo se produce
un molde esto entonces la éste que o
metría es muy importante tienen que
asegurarse de que el cambio coincida con
la éste kyo metría de la reacción lo
aprendieron aprendieron a determinar el
efecto de la manipulación de la reacción
química en los valores de cv y acá